let's now take a closer look at some of
the numbers in the Senate bill and how
that legislation could affect your
coverage because we're talking about
this Senate health care bill it faces
opposition after a Congressional Budget
Office report we now know that at least
six GOP senators now oppose the bill
right now there's not enough support to
bring it to a vote
there was this nonpartisan CBO estimate
that 22 million fewer people will have
insurance in 2026 under the Senate bill
compared with the new law and the new
estimate also it expects that the bill
would cut the deficit by 321 billion
dollars over the next decade and under
Obamacare a 21 year old earning about 57
thousand dollars a year would pay $5,100
for a silver plan a sixty four-year-old
with the same income would pay sixty
eight hundred dollars tax credits cover
part of that cost the Senate plan would
reduce to twenty one-year-old premiums
but the sixty four-year-old would pay
more than twenty thousand dollars the
older person would receive no tax credit
and could be charged up to five times
more than a younger person the White
House says the CBO cannot accurately
predict how health care legislation will
impact insurance coverage let's now take
a closer look at those senate numbers in
the senate bill and how the legislation
could affect your coverage shannon petty
piece White House correspondent for
Bloomberg News is with us from
Washington good morning so just after
sharing with our viewers those numbers I
mean what factors into how much someone
pays for health care two of the big
factors are the subsidies and how much
insurers can charge people who are older
as those charts Illustrated really well
insurers can now charge older people
more for insurance so a sixty
four-year-old someone in their 50s or
60s can now pay as much as five times a
healthy person so you see their costs go
up and at the same time the subsidies
for people who are sort of upper lower
middle income go down so they don't get
as much of a subsidy and a tax credit
and so that's what has these sort of
older lower income Americans feeling
really the burying the biggest brunt of
these changes why the tax benefits for
wealthy people
the fits in with larger Republican
ideology of cutting tax credits you know
believing that fewer taxes is going to
be better for economic growth one of the
key principles driving Republicans
desire to repeal place Obamacare is to
get rid of these taxes for that's part
of this bigger ideology of a low tax
economy now the largest savings come
from reductions in the Medicaid spending
and as you know nearly 70 million
Americans really rely on Medicaid so
what does this mean for them Shannon
eventually millions of people will lose
Medicaid coverage according to the CBO
estimate the expansion will eventually
be rolled back it'll be harder in the
future to qualify for Medicaid and
hospitals and nursing homes and
institutions that depend on those
Medicaid payments will eventually see
cuts as this bill reduces really how
much money is give to state and how
quickly the money given to States can
grow one of the things that Obamacare
did was required coverage of essential
benefits birth control maternity care
vaccines mental health this bill does
not so how would this affect coverage
well that's an excellent point so now
insurers do not have to provide these
sort of basic services you know even
doctor's visits prescription drug
coverage which they didn't have to do
before this law so if you have a
employee plan you don't think this
affects you well now your employer could
provide you a really skinny basic plan
that maybe doesn't even cover doctor's
visits or prescription drug coverage or
mental health or maternity care vaccines
so all those things even people who
think I have covered from my employer
well your employer doesn't have to
provide those things to you anymore
which they had to under the Affordable
Care Act how do they justify the fact
that it'll hurt the people that
supported them most enthusiastically
during the election you know this bill
really is in line with what Republicans
have been talking about ideologically
for more than eight years of course
they've been talking about repeal and
replace Obamacare they were elected on
that I don't think anybody doubted their
interest in repealing Obamacare but they
also don't like entitlements so the cuts
to the Medicaid program which is
something that you know a lot of
supporters and
States benefit from you know the
Republicans view that as an entitlement
and they feel that program has gotten
too big too expansive it's
government-run health care there's a lot
of waste in the system and they're
trying to bring it back to you know
people who are disabled or pregnant
women or children and not able-bodied
adults that's the Republican ideology
behind this all right Shannon petty
piece to be continued a lot of
discussion continues thanks a lot